what do you like best or least about
your job the editors of AE eyes
Political Report have been exploring
workers answers they find that most
workers are highly satisfied with most
aspects of their jobs in a Gallup poll
more than nine and ten employed people
said they were completely or somewhat
satisfied with the safety of their
workplace their co-workers and the
flexibility of their hours around 80
percent are satisfied with the amount of
work required of them the recognition
they get on the job and the amount of
vacation time they get 81 percent are
even satisfied with their boss or
supervisor in the poll workers would
least satisfied about their health and
retirement benefits and on-the-job
stress but even in these areas more than
two-thirds said they were satisfied
Americans views about the economy their
jobs and their futures are more positive
now than they have been in a long time
in a new Bloomberg poll nearly 6 and 10
said that they were moving closer to
their hopes for their careers and
finances that's good news on Labor Day
to learn more about my take on American
attitudes toward work see the new issue
of AE eyes Political Report also let us
know what other topics you want our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI